Why do rich people live longer than poor people?
Scientists have struggled to untangle the
causes for decades.
Is it differing lifestyles?
Access to health care?
Or does social status itself affect a person’s
health?
Well, it turns out a group of monkeys may
hold the answers.
Scientists recently decided to create social
groups among rhesus macaques, a social animal
that like humans form strict social hierarchies.
In the experiment, 45 female monkeys were
placed into 9 groups of 5, introducing new
monkeys 1 by 1 into their new group.
The first monkey in the group was always the
highest ranking with the last monkey ending
up at the bottom of the social order, experiencing
isolation and harassment.
The monkeys lived like this for a year, at
which point the scientists moved them around
again.
The monkeys with the same rank were were placed
in new groups, forming new social hierarchies
by again introducing monkeys one at a time.
So the monkeys who had all been at the top
of their first groups were now all together,
with four of the five now experiencing a new
social class.
Researchers then analyzed blood samples from
the macaques and found that immune cells taken
from the lower-ranking monkeys were more likely
to show increased inflammation, which has
been linked to a whole host of health problems.
Conversely, monkeys who went up in social
class experienced the opposite.
Their immune cells improved.
This study suggests that it’s not just behavior
or genetics that affect the monkeys’ health,
but that social hierarchy itself is also a
factor.
And according to Professor Graham Rook, from
University College London, “the evidence
is showing the findings are terrifically applicable
to humans.”
While this study was not conducted on humans,
we do know that social class plays a dramatic
role on our life expectancies.
For example, for men born in 1920 there was
a 5 year difference in life expectancy between
the top 10 percent and the bottom 10 percent.
But as the wealth gap in the U.S. became more
extreme over the years, so did the life expectancy
gap.
For men born in 1940, the difference in years
lived rose to an alarming 12 years.
So what can be done?
As one researcher of the the macaque study
put it, “if we could flatten the slope so
the difference between highest and lowest
weren’t as much… we could mediate some
of those consequences.”
So, based on this study, perhaps the long-term
cure for many ailments won’t come from medicine
after all, but from economic policies that
work toward a more equal society.